hi I'm Matt wells for recent TV I'm here
in Las Vegas at Freedom Fest and I'm
joined by michelle bernard school choice
reform advocate and hidden journalist
welcome tell us a little bit how you got
involved in the kind of school reform
movement sure absolutely education has
been an issue that's been important to
me my entire life but in particular a
few years ago I was you know like many
Americans sitting home watching
television the nation was celebrating
the fiftieth anniversary of Brown versus
Board of Education and and there was a
lot obviously to celebrate what I was
thinking you know isn't this interesting
we're celebrating the 50th anniversary
of Brown versus Board of Education I
live in the Washington Metropolitan Area
and many of the same arguments that my
parents had when I was a child and that
many parents have as to the inefficiency
of the DC public school system we were
still having 50 years later and I kept
thinking to myself what would Thurgood
Marshall be thinking if he could look at
the state of our nation's K through 12
education system it's not just from the
perspective of African American children
but all children particularly poor
children you know our schools are just
as separate and just as on people as
they were when he fought the Brown
versus Board of Education battle it's
not so much race-based now what we see
today is that education is that the
quality of your education is based on
your zip code and if you don't have a
great zip code your chance of really
realizing the America
dream is very very small and that has
what is what propelled me to really
dedicate most of my time and energy to
education so what specifically are you
advocating pushing and changing what do
you try to well personally I'm a real
big advocate personal choice I believe
school choice is the next evolution of
Brown versus Board of Education I think
that any parent regardless of zip code
or grandparent child caregiver concerned
citizen should be able to take their tax
dollars and put their child in the
school that they think best meets their
child's needs that beings that I believe
in comprehensive education reform from A
to Z one of the things that I am most
heavily focused on is really trying to
develop grassroots boots on the ground
civil rights moment of our time of
parents children grandparents concerned
citizens all across the nation that will
really march on Washington March on the
steps of their state legislators and
demand educational opportunity and
equality for all children in this
country today you know I I reflect back
on when I was a kid and I was studying
history and you look at the old history
books of the black and white photos from
that from that time period of Brown
versus Board of Education and ending
segregation in the United States and
that was a big civil rights movement not
a movement in our nation's history and
to me the education reform battle of
today is an extension of that movement
and that's what I'm working on that's
what I'm creating you know we've got the
academics and the policymakers and the
people who look at education reform from
that level I'm the person who really
wants to take it to a different level
and really meet with parents and meet
with
you know one of the things that that I
like to do is for example go into you
know low-income housing developments and
talk to parents and say you know what is
it that you want for your child and
every parent that I've ever met has
always said I want them to have an
excellent education and I don't want
them to have to live here and so what I
want to do is work with those people to
explain to them what do we mean when we
talk about school choice or parental
choice what do we mean by education
reform and also explain to parents that
they have the tools within themselves to
demand change from the government we are
seem to be living in a moment now where
there's a lot more traction for these
ideas Waiting for Superman a lot more
kind of bipartisan yeah opportunity what
do you foresee happening in the next
let's say five years or so well you know
I think that Waiting for Superman in the
cartel documentary called the boys of
Muraki have done a lot to make the
notion of education reform a part of pop
culture so for people who are very
wealthy live in zip codes where your
houses cost more and you have a really
good education and that you might assume
that all children have access to the
kind of kids schools that their kids do
it has its brought it it's brought at
home and so I think what we're going to
be able to revert to them I'm hoping we
will see in the next five years is a
broader coalition of people who are
dedicating themselves to school choice
into comprehensive education reform my
personal perspective is that when you go
out and you talk to and you know school
choice reformers by and large the people
who are really really engaged are white
they're males they are Christian they
are conservative you have Democrats and
left the center activists who as we sort
of make a joke and say that they're sort
of in the closet because they feel that
they're going to get beaten up by their
party or by their colleagues if they
speak out and say I'm for school
appearance for school reform I'm for
school choice I am Who I am you know
definitely in on the side of the
of the American population that believes
that we need to do something about the
power the teachers unions have on our
education system and so one of the
things I'm thinking we're going to see
in the next five years to see a broader
coalition that includes more people that
are Democrats more people that are left
the center and is more racially diverse
as well well thank you very much for a
recent TV I met well